in this lecture we would answer the
question that everyone has when they're
first talking about the mysteries of
time namely
why am i always late this is not a
question to which i can give a specific
answer it has more to do with your
circumstances than with any scientific
principles
but what we can do is talk about how
human beings perceive the passage of
time
how we in our brains and in our bodies
measure
time as it passes we already talked
about in earlier lectures the idea of
using a clock
to measure time a clock is something
that does the same thing
over and over again in a repetitive and
predictable way
compared to other clocks the reason why
we human beings feel the passage of time
is because our bodies have clocks in
them
we have things that happen in a rhythm
over and over again you have your
heartbeat
your breathing the pulses in your
central nervous system
biological clocks are not very reliable
compared to a good mechanical or
electronic clock
that's because our bodies are affected
by many things that are outside our
control whether we are
tired or exhausted whether we have
adrenaline rushing through our system
also our mental state are we focused on
something or are we distracted by
the world around us finally the way that
we get memories and keep them
affects how we perceive the passage of
time so we do feel time passing
in many ways it's pretty accurate but
there's always something that
makes us not completely perfect compared
to let's say a good
atomic clock to set the stage for this
discussion let's just talk about
biological rhythms more generally
in any organism there are things that
happen over and over again that's what a
rhythm is something that repeats itself
over and over
the heartbeat is probably the single
most fundamental rhythm
that advanced living organism has we can
compare
how these rhythms work in different
kinds of animals
and just to keep everything else as
constant as possible
we can compare how mammals have
different rhythms inside their bodies
one way of thinking about an advanced
organism like a mammal
is it's a network you have the brain and
you have all the different
things coming out of the brain the
nervous system your circulatory system
and so forth
and you can actually make predictions on
the basis of network theory
for how the rhythms cascade through your
body and then
compare those predictions to data so
jeffrey west at
the santa fe institute who studies
complexity he was a physicist at first
but he
went into complexity studies as that
field came to life and became more
exciting
has asked the question about how the
networks in different mammals are
affected by their size
you find two of the most basic
relationships
are that if you're a smaller animal your
networks move faster
in particular your heart beats faster
the smaller you are the less weight you
have
the faster your heartbeat is on the
other hand he found that
smaller animals also live shorter lives
the lifespan the typical lifespan
of a tiny little shrew is much shorter
than that of a giant elephant or a blue
whale
so if you think about this a smaller
animal has faster heartbeats
and also doesn't live as long a longer
larger animal has a slower heartbeat and
lives longer
you you might wonder do these effects
cancel out
and the answer is yes as a very rough
rule of thumb
every mammalian species on average has
the same number of heartbeats in its
lifespan
that number turns out to be one and a
half billion
roughly speaking every mammal gets one
and a half billion
heartbeats in its life now don't take
this
too seriously when i tell this to people
they sometimes worry that this is a
strict rule that no matter what you do
it's almost like predicting the future
you will live for one and a half billion
heartbeats and they wonder should i
exercise more should i exercise less to
get more or less heartbeats
that's not how it works it's an average
of course
many animals live a little bit shorter a
little bit longer but it's an
interesting feature of our biology that
somehow
a shrew and an elephant have similar
blueprints
just taking reality in different forms
in a really tiny form for the shrew and
a bigger one for the elephant
this kind of scaling law goes far beyond
organisms it goes all the way down to
the cellular level
west and his collaborators were able to
use this kind of scaling relationship
to make predictions for the rate at
which individual cells
behave in certain ways if they're in an
organism or outside an organism they
made predictions
which hadn't yet been tested after they
made the prediction they were tested
the idea that a human being is a complex
network
of smaller functions talking to each
other is a very good fit to how real
animals
live of course unlike shrews and
elephants and
blue whales we human beings have another
variable which is the culture
in which we find ourselves the
environment around us the human
environment
in which we're embedded and we all know
that different cultures
approach time differently the
psychologist robert levine who studies
how human beings interact with time
is based in fresno california but he
sometimes spends time in other countries
giving lectures and so forth he tells
a wonderful story of his first semester
in brazil
when he was going to give a lecture it
was scheduled to go from
10 a.m to noon it was a regular class he
was teaching
he's walking down the street and he
asked someone what time it was and they
said it was 905. he didn't have a watch
himself
so he says oh i have plenty of time to
get to my lecture at 10 o'clock
about half an hour passes and he asks
someone else what time it is and they
say it's 20 minutes after 10.
he panics he rushes to the lecture room
and there's almost no students there yet
he says
what is going on so he asks the students
what time it is one says it's 9 45
they're looking at their watches
one says it's 9 55 one says it's 5
minutes past
10. what levine realized was that no
one's clock
in brazil reads the same time and nobody
cares
the students sort of came in very very
gradually to the
10 a.m class by 11 a.m the room had more
or less filled up
but it wasn't that the students were
lazy or didn't want to go to the lecture
when noon came along he said that in
california when the end of the lecture
was scheduled you would know
every single student would be rustling
in their chair looking at the clock
ready to go
in brazil none of the students moved who
cares it was 12
o'clock at the end of the lecture they
were still interested they had questions
they kept discussing it became 12 30
eventually he had to escape the point is
that
different cultures approach time
differently levine also spent time in
japan and he says of course compared to
what you would do in california the
japanese found that his natural time
keeping was
incredibly lax and kept telling him to
hurry up in brazil they kept telling him
to calm down
it's not these anecdotes that are really
important what's important
is data can we actually do a scientific
experiment to justify
these stories about how different
cultures perceive time
and the answer is yes a bunch of
different studies have been done
to basically try to measure the pace of
life
in different cities different cultures
different environments for example
you can take how long it goes if you
walk up to a post office
and you want to order some stamps
psychologists have sent people to order
stamps in different post offices in
different cities throughout the world
and found consistent differences in how
long it takes to get those stamps to get
to you
there's also a study where you can just
measure how fast people are
walking you sit there in the cafe you
walk watch people walk by
you measure how fast they're moving and
once again you find
systematic differences in different
cultures and in different cities
for example you will not be surprised to
learn that in
higher population areas people walk
faster
people literally will walk faster down
the streets of new york city
than they will down the streets of a
small town in massachusetts
it's not because everyone else is
walking faster it's just because that's
what the environment does to you
another obvious effect is technology and
industrialization
psychologist richard weissman has
compared the pace of life in cities
over time so he does this walking
experiment he sees
how fast people are walking down the
street but rather than comparing one
city to
another one he compares one city 20
years ago to the same city
today what he found was that over the
last 20 years the pace of life has
increased by 10 percent that doesn't
sound like a lot 10
but it's only in 20 years how quickly
will it go over the next
century wiseman also found that the
effects are different from place to
place
singapore was up 30 percent guangzhou
a city in china was up 20 the areas of
the world that are developing and
industrializing and gaining high
technology the most quickly
also see their pace of life increasing
the most quickly
nevertheless your stereotypical guesses
aren't always right it turns out that
new york city
is far and away not the fastest walking
city in the world in fact it's behind
cities like
dublin and madrid and copenhagen there
are many
complex features that go into how
quickly life is lived in different
environments
technology and density are very
important but we are very far away from
having a complete theory of how this
works
another place where we're very far away
from having a complete theory is how
individual people perceive the passage
of time
there's one lesson that we have
certainly learned which is that
the human brain is not a computer
program
we think about the human brain as very
similar to computers because the human
brain clearly
computes in some sense we can mimic some
things the brain do
in a computer program but the way the
brain came together
is very different than the way you would
write a computer program the brain
developed over literally billions of
years of evolution of life here on earth
by an incremental change through random
possibilities being tested and seeing
what works
a computer program on the other hand is
usually written from the start
you have a task in mind and you're going
to design it from the top
down in the most efficient way you can
therefore in a computer program if you
want to store
data for example well you have a array
that you can put the data in and that's
that
in the brain any task that you might
want to do
is probably shared among many different
pieces because that's what was useful at
the time
in particular when it comes to keeping
time to measuring duration
there are different parts of the brain
that kick in
it's a highly distributed feature it's
not like a simple clock that you have in
your computer there's some chip
that has a rate that you can buy a
faster and faster chip
the brain has many many pieces each one
of which contributes to our
understanding of time
as one experiment to demonstrate this
that is very vivid
neurologists did an experiment with rats
and we should keep in mind is that
neurologists neuroscientists
hate rats they're constantly torturing
these poor little rats
so the rats have a brain much like we do
they're mammals you know
as far as all of life is concerned rats
are pretty close biologically to human
beings
they have a complex brain they have a
cerebral cortex which we
we have also it's the gray matter in our
brain the cerebral cortex
is the outside part of our brain it's
where we do our higher
information processing the life of
consciousness
is happening within our cerebral cortex
there's also
other organs inside the cerebral cortex
which are more primitive
we think of them as giving us
subconscious brain functions
so you can actually take a rat and
remove its cerebral cortex
remove sort of the advanced parts of its
brain
but the rat will still be alive it won't
be able to do
mazes and other things that we teach
rats to do but
what the neurologists neuroscientists
have found is that rats can still
tell time even with their cerebral
cortex removed
they give them a little task like
pushing on a lever
if they push on the lever once every 40
seconds they get a food reward
the rats without a cerebral cortex can
measure the time interval of 40 seconds
that means that whatever we're doing
when we're measuring duration and time
it's not a matter of our conscious brain
there are unconscious things going on
and there's more than one thing
going on another experiment with mice
was able to show that mice with their
whole brains intact
could keep track of at least three
different rhythms
these mice had three different paddles
that they would push to get food
and to get the food one paddle needed to
be pushed once every 10 seconds
once had to be pushed once every 3 30
seconds
and once had to be pushed once every 90
seconds the mice were able to separately
keep track
of the time intervals necessary to get
the rhythms right in all
three paddles simultaneously and you
might think well
30 seconds is 3 times 10 and 90 seconds
is 3 times 30 so you just
press this one three times and this one
once etc
but you could actually turn on and off
the rhythms you could displace the
rhythm so that the 10 second one was out
of phase with the 30 second one in the
90 second one
the mice could still keep track so
inside our brains is more than one
time keeping device in fact you can sort
of roughly divide it up into different
kinds of
time keeping as you are listening to
this lecture right now
there is a part of your brain that is
keeping track of what time of day it is
this is your circadian rhythm
that tells you when you wake up when you
go to sleep
there's another part of your brain that
is keeping track of how much time has
passed
since the lecture started or since you
started listening to it
and there are yet other parts of your
brain that are more or less like alarm
clocks they keep
the amount of time before some relevant
future event if you want to
go to dinner or go to bed or something
is going to happen
how much time do you have before that
happens your brain is keeping track of
that
now this is a complex set of operations
we don't have a grand unified theory of
everything this is why
brain science and biology is much more
complex than physics is
but neuroscientists have been able to
isolate at least three different
kinds of time perception three different
ways
in which we increase or decrease the
rate at which time seems to pass
for us the three ways are number one
pulses
sort of the basic way that you would
keep track of time in a
clock or with a pendulum going back and
forth there are pulses in our brains and
we simply count them
another thing that affects the passage
of time is our sensory input
and focus what are we paying attention
to and finally and sort of most
intriguingly
the way in which we accumulate memories
affects our notion of how much time has
passed the more memories we accumulate
the more time we attribute to what
happened so let's consider these three
aspects in order
when we say counting pulses it makes you
think that there
is a little part of your brain that is
almost like a pendulum
going back and forth and that is not
true or at least we don't know of any
single part of the brain that acts
exactly like a clock like the chip in
your computer
rather there are multiple levels of
pulses the different
neurons in your brain do work via pulses
it's not that the neuron is constantly
sending signals
it's that there's a signal or there's
not a signal so neurons turn on and off
there's multiple levels of pulses due to
all the neurons in our brain
and together they help us perceive the
passage of time
again you will not be surprised to learn
that we can affect
how quickly those pulses go for example
we can affect them through drugs
stimulants make our pulses beat faster
if you drink caffeine
the pulses in your brain that keep track
of time go a little bit faster
depressants will slow them down if you
have alcohol or other depressants even
something like marijuana
the pulses decrease in their rate and it
takes us longer to
accumulate a certain perceived amount of
time
now whenever we talk about this kind of
phenomenon we have to be very very
careful because people say well
you drink caffeine and time speeds up
but in fact as we talked about way back
when in the early lectures
time is always moving at one second per
second
when you want to say that time speeds up
what you mean is that one
clock has sped up compared to some other
clock
when you drink caffeine your clock
speeds up but what that means is that
when you compare it to the world
the world has slowed down so your clock
has sped up
compared to the outside world we have to
be sure to get that
right when we're talking about effects
on our internal clocks
these effects from stimulants or
depressants we think
are effects on the neurotransmitter that
send signals from our neurons
to other cells in our brain
neurotransmitters like dopamine and
other chemicals
are what the neurons send and they do it
in the form of pulses
caffeine or alcohol or other drugs can
make it easier
or harder for these neurotransmitters to
be sent that
speeds up or slows down our internal
clocks
but that's usually not what makes you
late if you want to know why you're
always late it might not have
anything to do with caffeine or booze or
anything like that
it's probably due to the second aspect
which is the sensory input and focus
when you are focused on a task when you
have you know a really hot first date
or when you're in a really engrossing
project for work or at home that you're
really in love with
you don't pay as much attention to the
outside world and in some sense which
psychologists still don't understand you
also don't pay as much attention to your
internal clocks
so your effective internal timekeeping
device
slows down the outside world speeds up
if you're having a really interesting
date or conversation with someone
you think that a half an hour has passed
but in fact it's been like two hours
your focus on one task makes it harder
for you to tell time
usually if you're late it's because
you've been focusing on something else
contrary wise if you're bored if you're
on a plane ride and there's nothing
going on
if you have a tedious aspect to your job
your attention is constantly flitting
around
you are not focused on any one thing and
the opposite effect happens
your internal clock seems to go faster
the outside world
slows down it seems to take forever to
get that plane ride across the country
simply because you're bored and your
attention keeps wandering
the final aspect is the rate at which we
form new
memories so this is a fascinating thing
that neuroscientists are just beginning
to understand
you might have as an example this idea
that if you're in a high stress
situation time seems to slow down by
which we mean
your clock speeds up the rest of the
world seems to slow down
this was uh noticed by a neuroscientist
named david eagleman long before he was
a working neuroscientist
when he was a child he once fell out of
a tree and it was long enough that
it was not so long that he was really
hurt long enough that he was very scared
as he was falling out of the tree and he
remembered
as he grew up and became a working
neuroscientist that
the world seemed to slow down if you've
ever been in an accident or a very very
stressful
sudden situation everything around you
seems to move more slowly
so eagleman wanted to know is it really
true that in these high stress
situations your internal clock
beats faster therefore making the rest
of the world seem to slow down
the problem with this question as a
working scientist is that to answer it
you need to scare people and that's not
really good procedure when it comes to
human subjects
but what eagleman did was to figure out
a way to scare people in a way that
wasn't really dangerous
he threw them off of a tall building but
he threw them off of a tall building
onto
a trampoline so it was actually
perfectly safe
and while they were falling off the
building the theory was they would get
scared there'd be adrenaline going
through them even though they knew there
was a trampoline down there they
they weren't surprised by the trampoline
and he had them actually do little
recognition tests he gave them little
pieces of equipment that would flash
numbers on a screen
and it flashed them either fast or slow
if they were so fast
they would be flat flashing so fast that
you couldn't recognize the numbers if
they were going slow
then you had the time to see what the
numbers were and what eagleman did was
to compare
how good you were at recognizing the
numbers when your adrenaline was running
and you were falling out of the building
versus when you were just sitting at a
desk calmly
the answer is there was no difference
despite the fact that there was
adrenaline going and your pulses were
racing you were not any better at
recognizing the quick flashing numbers
than you would have been sitting calmly
at your desk so therefore in that sense
the speeding up clock inside didn't help
you
perceive the outside world nevertheless
if you talked to the subjects
afterward they said that the outside
world slowed down they had a perception
that time had slowed down for them in
recollection
after the effect so there's a theory
about what is going on
the question the theory is and it's just
a theory it's not something that we can
test very accurately
that the more memories you accumulate
the more
time seems to have passed when you're in
a high stressed scary situation
your brain does its best to record
absolutely everything that has happened
it's scared it's looking around
it's accumulating a huge amount of data
even though it's not perceiving things
any more quickly than it would otherwise
when you think about that event
afterward you have more memories you
have more data to leave through
and therefore it seems to us like more
time
has passed this hypothesis
is gets a little bit of support from a
related fact which again
everyone knows even if you haven't been
in a scary situation
you know that time seems to pass more
quickly as we age
when you're older the summer seems to
rush by
when you were a kid the summer seemed to
last forever this is not just an
anecdote this is not just
an idea that people have this is
something that you can test
the theory that eagleman has and other
people have
is simply that when you're young in the
summertime you're going to the beach and
whatever it's all
new to you everything around you is a
new experience
when you're older you've been there
before it's a little bit more blase
so it seems to pass more quickly for you
compared to what it did when you were a
child and this is something that again
we can try to test
the way that neuroscientists have tried
to test it is to give 20 year olds
a test where they're simply told
starting now
tell me after three minutes had passed
and then they give the same test to
60 year olds and the answer is that 20
year olds are pretty good
at measuring about how long three
minutes are so they have no clocks
around them they're just sitting there
quietly in an empty room they say three
minutes have passed and on average
the actual amount of time that is passed
is about three minutes and three seconds
very very accurate
but you do exactly the same test to 60
year old people
and when they say three minutes have
passed the actual elapsed time is more
like
three minutes and 20 or 40 seconds
so 20 year olds are better at estimating
time than 60 year olds
for an older person it takes longer for
the same amount of subjective time
to pass the theory is that that's
because they don't create as many new
memories
but the fact is that it does take longer
there's even a hypothesis that tries to
make it quantitative
that says the amount of time we
experience grows logarithmically
with our age it would be very hard to
put exact data about that
but it makes sense to us think back to
that boring plane ride if you're on a
boring plane ride it seems to last
forever
but if you recall it after the fact it
seems to go by very quickly
you might remember that you were bored
but you don't have some elaborate memory
of every single event because none of
the events were interesting
you're you were not focusing so your
subjective time at the time seemed to
last forever
but you were also not making new
memories so your subjective time
after the fact seems to make the trip
actually quite short
another aspect that is very interesting
when it comes to how human beings
perceive
time is a simple statement that we live
in the past
so forgetting about measuring time using
our internal clocks
what about when we actually just
perceive the moment now
we all think whether we're presentists
or eternalists that there is a moment
called now we are perceiving it we're
looking around we're getting data sense
data from outside of ourselves
and we experience what we call the
present moment
it turns out of course and if you
thought about it a little bit it would
make sense
that what we call the present moment
isn't the present moment
that's because it takes time number one
for the information to get to us
and number two for our brain to process
that information the most
obvious example of this is if you see
lightning very very far away you see it
and we all know that if lightning is far
away it takes time for the sound to get
to us you can even count how many
seconds it takes
and figure out how far away the
lightning storm is that's because sound
moves more slowly than light
but it's not just the external world
that matters it's the internal world
that matters as well
so for example you can do this at home i
won't demonstrate
but you can touch your nose and you can
also touch your toes
do it at the same time put your finger
to your nose and to your toes
and what you will notice is that you
feel the touch
simultaneously if you perform the touch
simultaneously you will feel the touch
simultaneously
that seems very natural to us but it
shouldn't be natural because the amount
of time it takes the nerve
signal to travel from our nose to our
brain
is much less the amount of time it takes
the nerve signal to travel from our feet
to our brain now the nerves are moving
pretty quickly
but we as our our brains are very very
good at measuring tiny differences in
time
more than good enough to be able to
measure the difference between the
signal coming
from our feet and the single coming from
our face
nevertheless we don't perceive that
difference we perceive
the simultaneous touches as simultaneous
events
why is that it's because our brain
knows that our feet are further away and
takes that into consideration
it turns out that what we consider to be
the correct moment
right now is actually about 80
milliseconds
in the past the way that you can get
that number one simple way to do it is
to watch a person dribbling a basketball
as they're dribbling the basketball you
both see it and hear it just like the
lightning bolt
and your brain corrects for the fact
that it takes the sound longer to get
to you so as the person dribbling the
basketball moves away
you see and you hear the sound at the
same time in your brain
until they get so far away that it takes
more than 80 milliseconds for the sound
to get to you
at that point suddenly there's a
mismatch between the sound that gets to
you
and the sight that's because you get the
vision of it and you put together that
in the conscious now
before the sound can get to you so we
live
about 80 milliseconds in the past and
really the primary lesson to learn from
this
is that consciousness is kind of a messy
thing it's very difficult
to understand what's going on in the
brain because it's a very elaborate
mechanism
this is why physics is the right thing
right field of study to go into if you
have a short attention span
speaking of which people have different
attitudes toward
time and this has nothing to do with
culture this is just within any one
culture
individual human beings approach time
differently
it turns out the psychologists have
shown that our orientation toward
time is a crucial component
of how we live the rest of our lives
there's a great experiment that
illustrates this called the stanford
marshmallow experiment it was first done
by walter mitchell
a professor at stanford in 1972 and it's
a simple setup
you offer a child a marshmallow you you
fool the child first every psychology
experiment involves fooling the subject
into thinking that
it's an experiment about something else
so you make the kid do something and
then as a reward you say
here is a marshmallow for being a good
test subject but then you say i have
another marshmallow you first check that
the kid likes marshmallows
i can give you a second marshmallow if i
need to go out of the room for a few
minutes if you
wait and you don't eat that first
marshmallow i will give you a second one
when i come back
so roughly speaking when you do this
experiment on three or four year old
kids
only about a half or a third of them can
actually wait
for you to come back the kids eat the
marshmallow some of them
others are very very patient they use
elaborate strategies of self-deception
looking around trying their best not to
look at the marshmallow the claim of
modern psychologists is that the
difference
between eating the first marshmallow
immediately and waiting to get two
marshmallows
later shows you something about your
orientation toward time
there are people who really in some
sense dwell
in the past what they care about most
what they're talking about all the time
are what happened in the past what
happened they were growing up
high school college whatever there are
other people who live in the present
they want something right now they want
that marshmallow there it is and they're
going to eat it
there are other people who are future
oriented they know that there is some
benefit coming to them in the future
they will sacrifice the marshmallow
right in front of them to get that
marshmallow in the future they're future
oriented
this is not a matter of being rational
or irrational
economists will tell you it makes
perfect sense to
discount something that is a reward that
you won't get until the future
if someone offers you ten dollars now or
eleven
11
10 years from now you should just take
the 10
now because our brain says how do we
know that they'll be around 10 years
from now to give us the 11
that is a perfectly rational thing to do
nevertheless the ability to take the
future just as seriously as we take the
present
turns out to be a good predictor through
how we approach
many things in our lives the
psychologist philip zimbardo also at
stanford
has done a follow-up study on mitchell's
marshmallow
study he studied now the kids who were
three and four years old they're now in
high school and in college
what he found was that children who
waited who got the second marshmallow by
being good
scored higher on their sats had better
behaviors in school
and more scholastic achievement it turns
out that our attitude as human beings
toward
time is a crucial component in making us
who we are
[Music]
so
[Music]